maybe Mark Steyn can explain he's an
author and columnist of course a friend
of the show and he joins us now so I
wonder mark as these best legal scholars
lecture us from their purchase on cable
television about how the Constitution
requires John Brennan of a security
clearance and if he doesn't our first
moment rights are being violated do they
notice that people's freedom of
expression is being violated every day
in real ways across the country by the
tech Titans did do you think that even
compute sir they're taking too much
money from Google to care no you're
right you're right there's a
contradiction there and the left's
position seems to be which is amazing
actually when you think when you think
back 15 years when they were all going
bananas because george w bush was
supposedly trying to find out what
library books
you were reading there apparently now
cool with spooks having super First
Amendment privileges now I I'm actually
with senator Blumenthal I think we might
as well have a constitutional right to a
security clearance because four years
about three or four years ago just under
five million people in this country had
security clearances which is more than
the population of New Zealand or Norway
and that's one of the reasons for the
dysfunction of the intelligence
community I think it's now down to about
four and a half million with security
clearances but at that level actually
everybody might as well have security
clearances so I'm with senator
Blumenthal security grins is for in fact
in an effort at bipartisan compromise I
think that as unaccompanied minors are
coming across the Rio Grande in a skiff
that ice should hand them their security
clearances so go for it I like that idea
and it's probably going to come true but
the irony again there's so many layers
of it but that these are the exact same
people who are telling us that we don't
have a right to know what our government
is doing we don't have a right to know
the pretext under which Carter Page was
spied upon by the Obama administration
and we're by the way quislings if we ask
too many questions
but somehow John Brennan
has a right to agree classified
information I mean how could you how
could you make that argument without
turning red with shame under its
inactivate if you read John Brennan's
column in The New York Times it's
actually faintly creepy because at one
point he actually says at one but I want
to make sure I get this right that a
variety a variety of politicians
political parties media outlets think
tanks and influences that means Utica
you're an influencer you're readily
manipulated wittingly and unwittingly by
russian intelligence
so you tucker you don't even know you're
being manipulated by russian
intelligence but the fact that you're
objecting to john brennan telling you
you're being manipulated by russian
intelligence is the clearest proof that
you're being manipulated by russian
intelligence this is all this guy's got
and this is why if he wants to be this
idiotic in public if he wants to be just
another obscure MSNBC pundit he should
do it without a security clearance and
one one other thing Tucker when they say
oh this is the action of dictatorships
you can say a lot of things about
dictatorships but one of the things that
you can say with certainty is when the
dictator removes you as head of the
intelligence security apparatus actually
you lose your security clearance in not
only dips in in dictatorships in almost
all other countries this idea of
ex-officio security clearance it's bad
enough you know one of the ridiculous
things about this country is because you
don't have AI counts and Dukes
somebody who was a senator from 1972 to
1978 gets called senator until the day
he dies and now we're saying that aside
from that he should also have a security
clearance until the day he does
ex-officio security clearances are a
stupid idea and they should be abolished
across the board in real dictatorships
former intel heads wind up like barrier
stupid thank you great to see you as
always